it has been 49 years since roe versus
wade created a fictional right to
abortion in america that case was
reaffirmed slightly changed but
reaffirmed nonetheless in the planned
parenthood vkc decision now we are
looking at what could be
one of if not the most consequential
case in the history of the supreme court
dobbs versus jackson women's health
organization
which could
overrule all of it it could kill roe vs
wade roe versus wade would be kept
comfortable
would be it would be there would be a
conversation that would ensue between
the voters of america and we very
possibly could end abortion
in america so who better to discuss
these possibilities with than the head
of students for life my friend kristen
hawkins kristen thank you for being here
thanks for having me today this is a
monumental year it's not it's not 50 yet
it's the 49th march for life it's 49
years since roe v wade is rowe going to
make it to 50 absolutely not
there's a great hope that
this june when the supreme court hands
down their decision and dobbs that we
will see a reversal a gutting of roe vs
wade and
knowing that the supreme court can
disappoint and has disappointed and
conservative appointed judges have
disappointed how confident are you that
while we're told this is a 6-3
conservative court
john roberts is not particularly
conservative brett kavanaugh there are
some questions neil gorsuch redefined
sex and the boss doc case amy barrett so
there are these
there are some questions is there is
there a possibility that you get a
couple squishes and row continues yeah i
think the question right now is chief
justice roberts and trying to broker
some sort of compromise there where they
would uphold the mississippi law that
bans painful abortions at 15 weeks these
dismemberment abortions which would then
allow other states to go forth and ban
second and third trimester abortions but
then would they create a new standard so
the kc standard was viability if they
would come up with a compromise it would
be some sort of new standard like 15
weeks but it's really difficult because
really you know even last year the uh
one of the medical journals they said
that they think pain can actually even
start at 12 and a half weeks so it's
always kind of changing that threshold
is changing based on the newest research
and it's just kind of a random standard
because you know i can put an anesthetic
on or saying i don't feel pain so can
you lot my hand off i don't i don't
think that absolutely and viabilities
and viability changes depending on what
hospital you were born in what type of
equipment they have
you know what kind of medical care your
mother had so even this viability
24-week standard there's babies being
born who are who are living today who
are born at 21 weeks right so that that
could be the compromise it would still
be a win for the pro-life movement
babies would still be saved um i think
that's probably the worst case scenario
you're saying the worst case scenario
would be to uphold the pro-life law but
not overrule yes but leave row intact
and come up with some sort of arbitrary
new standard the feeling on on mo both
sides i believe and i think you can read
planned parenthood's panicked
fundraising emails and text messages
that i get is that because they were
willing to even take up the case it
means there's a significant majority
willing to
reconsider roe entirely well that's
wonderful news
we hope hope is a theological virtue
you are launching an initiative called
the final
fight for freedom that's right
we all fight for freedom you hear there
are a lot of movements oh that's the
fight for freedom we're fighting we love
freedom everyone loves freedom
the most interesting word there to me is
final why is this the final fight for
freedom well we think about it as this
battle of this first fight for freedom
of the the fight for americans to
self-govern right to determine our fate
and then the second uh fight for freedom
determining that every american deserves
full rights no matter their skin color
right it was fought during the civil war
extended into the civil rights movement
but then 1973 something else happened
when seven men said well your right to
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
is determined based on where you are
your location the fact that you you are
out of the womb and it fundamentally
disorder that hierarchy of rights that
we have putting someone else's pursuit
of happiness over someone else's right
to life and we know throughout history
we have done that plessy uh dred scott
that the court has had to go back and
reverse itself um but we feel like this
this is this final fight um because as
you know abraham lincoln said
you have to give freedom to the slave in
order to ensure freedom for the free and
if these children these innocent
children don't have the freedom to be
born yeah all our freedoms are at stake
because it's not as though the right to
life is just one right among many yeah
you know you have the right to life we
have the right to medical care maybe we
have the right to a social security
check no
and it's by the way it's not even as
though life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness are all on one level you as
you i think imply quite well
you can't pursue happiness if you don't
have liberty and you can't have liberty
if you don't have a life so
by the way i don't think that these
these
leftists these these pro-abortion people
who are screaming and yelling with their
crazy-looking hair and their you know
demonic sounding chants
and they had the hats
and and i i don't think they're really
pursuing happiness when i when i look at
the supreme court i see the pro-lifers
they're nice they're they seem so
well-adjusted i feel like they are but
they are the most miserable people on
earth the pro-abortion people yes that's
right so they're not even pursuing
happiness i really because they live for
self they don't live for others it's the
you know the principles of universal
happiness not to get theological right
no i mean well but but
i'm glad you brought that up because
very often i i find today a lot of
conservatives pro-lifers i know there
are people on the left who are who are
pro-life as well so i don't want to
exclude them either but very often
we will accept the scientific
materialist premises of our modern
culture so we'll always try to ground
everything in biology why can't uh
hulking dude go into the girls bathroom
well because the science shows that he
has a y chromosome no well there are
other reasons too well biologically the
swimmer on the girls team
is a huge dude who has an obvious
physical advantage
it's it's more than just biology it's
more than just the the baby in the womb
feeling pain it's more than just a
heartbeat even it's what what are we
beyond the the merely physical and that
requires
philosophical and theological engagement
you can't get around it that's right and
it's interesting because so often when
we're on campuses we approach it from a
scientific human rights standpoint you
know we're not leading the argument i
was doing an interview the other day and
someone goes why do you all bring up
religion like the only time anyone ever
actually brings up religion are
pro-abortion people you you brought a
religion in my face
you brought it up but since you have
let's talk about because um we kind of
already start with the premise that you
know that human life has value but
that's actually an interesting point
because uh i started seeing this post
covid and some of the conversations aka
debates that i have you know folks who
come to my speeches on campus where i've
actually had pro-abortion students i'll
back them up we'll be talking about
abortion i'll be asking them questions
and i'll actually back them up and say
well let's stop talking about the
pre-born because i've already proved to
you that that preborn child is a human
i've proved that science is not a
giraffe it's not a platypus yes i can't
have a koala bear as much as i want
quality i cannot make one with my
husband right tried it won't happen
right um so we've already proved it to
human but what we're disagreeing about
is does that human being have value but
let's first start with do you have value
and where does your value come from and
that's actually very scary because we do
live in the post-christian culture they
can't even answer the question
i had two kids two young boys actually
last semester when i asked them do you
have value as a human being told me no
right honestly i mean these were genuine
discussions and they genuinely didn't
believe they have value so it's a this
is a major cultural problem though
because i mean i speak as i was an
atheist for 10 years i'm quite familiar
with the very shallow atheistic
arguments and
they i think in sincerity are looking
around and they say okay if i can't see
it if i can't touch it it's not real
and so
my hopes my joys my loves my dreams
mathematics and certainly god himself
the maker of the universe
i can't really see them i can't compre
so it's just not real and
then if you look around and say okay if
the matter is all that really matters
then no i don't have any value but but
it's funny on this topic of religion
that the the left is always throwing
religion at you because they accuse
religious people of magical thinking of
fantastical thinking but sister mayor i
think just did that in the dobbs hearing
right right could you
could you imagine any more magical
thinking any more fantastical thinking
than believing that a baby is a baby if
you want the baby but a baby is not a
baby if you don't want the baby and if
if a pregnant woman is murdered
then that is double homicide but if the
woman herself chooses to go and kill the
baby that's not homicide at all
how do they how do they make that
argument
not not very convincingly i guess yeah i
mean it's a dumb founding argument right
it makes you want to take your head and
pound it against the ball because you
can point out i mean those are the
arguments when folks come to my
presentations on campus i love because
all i do is have to repeat back what
they've said to me and i know they
themselves have changed the minds of
those mushy in the audience i haven't
had to say anything right i just pointed
out the illogical position that those
who accept abortion have to take they
have to take this illogical argument and
in fact like i mean it goes on because
then you can ask well what separates a
newborn child from a child who's a month
old outside of the room what's the
difference there right
i know that some people especially
people who haven't had kids they think
that there is a huge categorical
difference between a three-day old baby
and a baby in the womb
your baby cannot do anything on his or
her own until well probably until he's
about 12 but but certainly not a 12 year
old it's going to be later than that i
think right
certainly a newborn baby is just as
helpless as just as vulnerable is just
as much in need of his or her mother
exactly they're actually more time
consuming more expensive i loved being
pregnant being pregnant it's easy i took
a baby with me everywhere i went right
having a newborn i had to take all the
gear i had to take all the medicine for
my children like it was crazy like all
much stuff it took like two hours just
to go to applebee's right and yes we go
to applebee's because we're boring
midwesterners but i mean so it it is
it's unbelievable the illogical
positions that in order to be
pro-abortion now uh in our culture with
all the science and technical all
technology has proved that you have to
accept it it's clearly illogical so with
all of this kind of crazy magical
thinking that's going on especially on
college campuses you're seeing religion
rates plummeting you're seeing sexual
confusion go through the roof you're
seeing men who believe that they're
women and vice versa and everybody has
10 different genders and we are legion
or something
what about pro-life are we are we losing
the utes or is pro-life gaining momentum
on campus we actually gain momentum we
just are students life's institute for
pearl advancement just released the poll
this week of gen z gen y the you know
the third of our electorate the largest
voting bloc good thing or bad thing
mostly a bad thing for republicans i
would say um and the poll numbers aren't
as bad as you would think they are in
fact they're pretty nuanced and in many
ways we win um
six out of ten originally said they
supported roe we in one line told them
what row and doe did right that these
two decisions 1973 allow abortion all
nine months for every reason
10
instant shift 10 point shift then we
were 50 50. wow instantly with one line
just explaining what the case is just
explain when we talked about chemical
abortion the rise of now this is going
to be the most prevalent form of
abortion this year this is what the my
administration has been rushing through
the day that they pulled the johnson
johnson vaccine because one person died
the fda came out and said they were
pouring all common sense regulations on
chemical abortion pills even though
dozens of women have died and all the
babies have died and all the babies have
died they pulled those regulations in
december when we polled
young people and by the way the majority
of the poll were not conservatives
66 out of 10
were wanting to these common sense
regulations you thought it was like duh
a woman should be um confirmed that
she's actually pregnant before she's
given these drugs it should be confirmed
that she's not experiencing atomic
pregnancy that could kill her it should
be confirmed that she's not rh negative
so she'll never be
never be able to carry another child to
term i mean these things make sense to
even pro-choice or liberal leaning young
people um and so the numbers aren't as
bad as many conservatives think when it
comes to abortion in fact i when i'm at
conservative events i'm always telling
you know the run of the mill
conservative like you actually need me
i'm like your best marketing arm for the
republican movement because
you this is a movement that brings a
diverse group of students and young
people and we're a very diverse movement
students for life because they see this
not as a political battle but as a human
rights battle they've seen their
brothers and sisters via ultrasound
many folks come into our movements and
our campus groups or their tenant groups
uh not political at all don't want to
pay attention to politics but then as
they kind of get sucked into the
movement they say oh my goodness if i
care about this i need to care about
that and then i slowly got to witness
the transformation from like liberal
atheist democrat to
sold out you know confirmed
staffer working on capitol hill for one
of the top republicans in the senate
someone going into the priesthood i mean
the atheists who then became evangelical
you know like it's crazy the
transformations that begin this is a
great observation because for many years
we have been told by conservatives by
the the squishy conservatives people
here in dc you know yes we're speaking
from dc right now the march for life is
happening the students for life summit
is happening and there are a lot of
swamp creatures around here who are
squishes and they say the way that
you're going to bring over liberals and
independents and leftists is
just don't talk about the culture just
talk about lowering taxes and then once
people want their taxes lowered then
they'll come in on these other issues
but what you're saying it's the opposite
if you convince someone that human life
matters and we are the ones who care
about human life and that's the thing
too is the accusation often raged
against pro-lifers is that we don't care
about women right right what are we
going to do when roe is reversed when
thousands and thousands of women or we
even though thousands and thousands of
women certainly did not die per year of
back alley abortions before roe but yeah
but what are we gonna do without the
women you say oh by the way have you
ever met the pro-life movement we've
been operating nearly 2000 pregnancy
centers every single day for decades we
offer all of these resources and support
this is who the pro-life movement is
we're actually a movement of love and
compassion we really put our money where
our mouth is um what better way to show
young people who may have a negative
brand associated with the word
republican or conservative that we care
about people because we're fighting for
them just to be born in the first place
that's right it's very basic stuff you
convince them on life on things that
matter the taxes will follow you really
are in the fight i i am very excited for
this next initiative for all the great
work and
gosh we have so much more to talk about
what are we going to do after roe versus
wait how are we going to keep fighting
not just to send this issue back to the
to the states but to to end abortion
nationwide we're going to have to hold
that until after the overrule road we'll
have you back yeah and go to students
for life.org slash fight we have our
whole battle plan for post roast you can
download it for free and get all the
details terrific kristen hawkins of
students for life a great organization
that i'm very excited to speak to on
this 49th anniversary of not just roe
versus wade before the 49th anniversary
of the pro-life movement gaining more
and more strength each year and
hopefully getting a whole lot more
strength this year as we move into a
post-row world see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you